major breaking news from within the
world of the democratic party
senator bernie sanders according to aids
has not ruled out running for president
again in 2024 if joe biden doesn't run
there is a very interesting article in
the washington post
senator bernie sanders is open to
running for president in 2024 if biden
declines to seek re-election according
to a campaign memo a top political
advisor distributed to allies on
wednesdays on wednesday and shared with
the washington post quote in the event
of an open 2024 democratic primary
senator sanders has not ruled out
another run for president so we advise
that you answer any questions about 2024
with that in mind this is a memo from
faz shakir close sanders advisor
who managed his campaign in 2020 the
memo was shared by a person with direct
knowledge of its contents on the
condition of anonymity because it was
not released publicly and confirmed by a
second person with direct knowledge of
the contents so many in my audience have
been clamoring saying 2024 will finally
be the time for bernie
everybody will realize that it was a
mistake in 2016 for him not to be the
nominee
and it was a mistake in 2020 for him to
be not be the nominee and or it was
stolen from him and 24 is when bernie
will sail to the nomination and then
sail to the presidency
i think that this is a really bad idea
i know many in my audience will be
furious with me i like bernie i
supported bernie in 2016. i supported
bernie in 2020. yes i acknowledged when
bernie no longer had a shot in those
campaigns and said well i'm going to
vote for the best alternative of those
who are left but i'm a bernie supporter
from 2016 and 2020.
i don't think bernie should talk about
running in 2024 i don't even think
bernie should be considering running in
2024 and i'm ready for the hate
at this point
bernie sanders
has become
a perennial candidate in the sense of
the guy who always runs and never wins
it doesn't mean he never could have won
or should have won or that it wouldn't
have been a great president i think he
would have
bernie will be 83 years old in 2024
his term would start in 2025 he would be
i don't remember what month he was born
in but he would be 87 or 88 at the time
that this bernie sanders term would end
this just doesn't seem if you zoom out
big picture
30 000 foot view like the direction that
the democratic party should go to say
okay
we've had
what we've had in the last eight years
we uh we have all the history that we've
had
let's make our nominee after all of the
criticisms of wanting and needing
someone younger than biden
let's go
with the 83 year old who lost twice
it just doesn't seem like the way to go
and i'm i'm willing to hear other
arguments and i'm ready for people to
cancel me over this
but it doesn't seem like the best thing
for the party
i don't really care about the party it
also doesn't seem like the best thing
for the progressive movement which i do
care about
now who's better than bernie
that's a separate segment we're not even
through the midterms there that that's
that's a different conversation
but it's time
for a new generation to lead not someone
even older than biden who's lost twice
and i hate to say it these are tough
this is a tough pill for me to swallow
but who's not nearly as popular as
looking at twitter and reddit makes it
seem that's the reality
uh i think it's been enough and quite
frankly i worry that it could even start
to border on embarrassing and kind of a
joke if bernie runs again i think that
there will be a lot of very unserious ah
this is this is a joke type reactions if
bernie runs again in 2024 i don't
question the genuine desire of bernie
to
do what he wants to do and that he cares
about the thing i i share it i'm aligned
with him i'm highly aligned i'm not
speaking as an ideologue here i'm
speaking as a strategist
and thinking about what makes the most
sense from that perspective in 2024
with respect this is my view i don't
hate anybody i'm not attacking anybody i
just think this is not the right way to
go so my thought would be
don't run in 2024 bernie i i am ready i
am so ready to hear your thoughts find
me on twitter at d pacman tell me
whether you agree or disagree
any responses to this
that are toxic ad hominems some will be
anti-semitic even though it's crazy i'm
jewish and bernie's jewish but this is
the type of commentary that leads to
anti-semitic replies from summoned miata
it's all going to go where it belongs
straight into the trash but substantive
replies i'm ready for find me at on
twitter at deepakman
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 percent off all products and free
shipping go to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below